before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
gone
but not forgotten
well I think I'm overdue to revisit
another Doctor Who list this time I'm
going to revisit the best one time
Doctor Who villains of the modern era
because honestly
um trying to do it to include classic
it brings in most of classic because you
know you had your dialects your Cybermen
and the master but most other things
they were one and done and I am too far
behind on trying to catch up on classic
I am working on that you know what one
of these days these lists are going to
become much more comprehensive but for
right now still restricting it to the
modern era and we are taking a look at
villains who appeared only in one story
now to be clear I do count two parters
as a single story but as long as we
understand that moving forward these are
who I think are the 10 best one-time
villains so let's start at number 10 and
work our way up
number 10.
zelin from the Jody Whitaker era episode
can you hear me now
um I am somewhat a defender of this
episode it's not quite as well liked as
I would um appreciate to be not as well
liked as I like it anyway I love this
episode a lot and I like actually both
the villains in this but I really like
zelen the delivery of the lines he is
just so
smug
but not quite clever enough but in a
real creepy way because when you get
really smug villains it's very easy to
have them just be punchable
but you feel like
if I try and punch you for being smug
I feel like I'm gonna get dissolved out
of reality he projects that that
smugness comes from legitimate power and
there's just so many little moments
where he just feels in such control and
the malevolence that comes from him in
so many of the moments that he has in
this from the moment when this mother
puts his kid to bed and says there is no
such thing as the bogeyman and she
leaves and there's Zealand just standing
there that's not
or just the way he feigns humbleness
when the doctor suggests that for him to
be what he claims he'd have to be some
kind of Otherworldly almost infinitely
powerful being and he just goes my block
the sense of strength coming from him is
so good
it is I think not a completely invalid
criticism to say that he is uh and his
partner in crime they're kind of
defeated a little bit too easily I
addressed that when I most recently
talked about the episode as a whole I
don't disagree with it but I do think
that the episode did allocate time to
where it was a little bit more important
than that but that's the reason he is as
low as he has despite the fact that I do
love him
number nine
the four told otherwise known as The
Mummy on the Orient Express
this thing
first of all Fantastic look such a
classic monster look like just updated
enough to have that little extra air of
like being a little bit more ooh like
looking a little sticky or a little
gooier but also being incredibly
evocative of a very classic looking uh
movie horror monster and the the gimmick
around this thing that the only one who
can see it is the one who's going to die
and the timer the fact that the timer is
on screen counting down until it reaches
them
and they die
it is such a simple and yet deeply
unsettling style of threat everything
about this thing just makes you
uncomfortable the way that it operates
the way that it looks it's a really
terrific monster now some might argue
that the True Villain of this episode is
Gus
um which is the computer that has kind
of set this whole thing up I would say
that functionally the foretold is the
obstacle so I'm going to count it as the
villain in this case regardless it's not
higher because it doesn't have a lot of
particular personality or whatnot we do
learn a little bit about at the very end
which I think in a way that is quite
Nifty but it doesn't uh it doesn't have
that force of personality to boost it up
higher but I do love it
number eight
the Vashta Narada from the two-parter in
series four silence in the library and
Forest of the Dead the Shadows that eat
people not every shadow
but any shadow
and once they latch on they don't let go
and you are nothing but food to them
Darkness
something you cannot avoid forever
but is the thing that will kill you and
the subtlety of the having two shadows
and knowing that you're gonna die and
just trying to figure out a way to stall
it however you can but
once they've got you
that's it
it shows a similar Simplicity to
something like the Weeping Angels which
is just completely built off that notion
of I suppose that statue was in a
different position before whereas this
just feeds off of
well as the doctor puts it that
irrational fear of the dark except that
it's not irrational there is something
in the dark that's a really good simple
thing to just press on for a monster or
a villain
that sensation you get that you tell
yourself oh there's nothing to worry
about there what if there is
perfectly used in the story in which
they appeared absolutely excellent
number seven
house
a sentient trash ball with no physical
being that you can relate to it all it's
a green glow and a voice
but when that voice is Michael Sheen
going full deep throated just Wicked
sadistic
yeah that is all you need
the threat of this thing and honestly
it's incorpore reality
contributes to that it makes him more
threatening somehow the fact that he's
not just something that you could in
theory blow up or punch
how do you deal with this thing that has
this degree of power that has lured you
into a trap and just wants to play
does not think that there is anything
you can do to stop him
might well be right
he doesn't really care what happens to
you
but whatever does he'd like it to be fun
there's a lot of reasons to love the
episode The Doctor's Wife but he's a big
one
number six
Mr Finch
leader of the krillitaines and performed
masterfully
by Anthony Stewart head
what I love about him is the sense of
presence he brings
there are a lot of villains that
ultimately don't really feel like that
much of a threat to the doctor and
sometimes that's logistical their plan
doesn't seem like they are really on top
of things but a lot of it just comes
down to presence
to have someone stand Toe to Toe face to
face with the doctor especially a doctor
as commanding as tenant could be even
that early into his run
and have that person just talk
just talk
and come across like a genuine threat a
genuine match for the doctor
the next time we meet
you enjoy with me
I promise you
that's huge
that is
enormous and Anthony Stewart head has
the presence to do that
when he faces down tenant
it really does feel like these are two
people who could legitimately take each
other apart and then the anger that he
gets to to just project later on in the
episode the severity in his face it's so
great and I have given up
hoping that he'll ever come back
I used to say there's no reason that you
can't bring him back yes like the krilla
things were blown up but it was already
established that he was like a bit
different from the rest of them like
they all got splashed with that oil all
the rest of them were all like ah he was
just standing there so clearly it wasn't
impacting him the same he could have
survived that explosion
he won't come back
but it will be so amazing if he did
number five
the dream Lord
so many of these have such incredible
performances at their Center Toby Jones
the
Wicked little Goblin and twisted mirror
to Matt Smith's 11th Doctor where Matt
Smith is Whimsical playful
the dreamlord
is Machiavellian
sadistic it's a perfect match off of
each other and again like some of the
other ones I've already mentioned that
smugness that he has that really gives
you a sense that no he's legitimately in
control ask me what happens if you die
in reality what happens you die stupid
that's why it's called reality like
exactly what he's capable of what he's
aiming for we don't know but he is in
control of this moment
and he knows it and he plays it like
that and how he'll just use
all these cutting lines to take down the
doctor pull apart his quirks if you had
any more toroidery quirks you could open
up a Tory Quirk shop the banter and just
slam the entire process of a normal
episode all the things you do doctor
that normally get you through these
things they won't work with me
oh oh he's another one who I think you
there is a way to bring him back I don't
know if it would work the same because
you could make an argument that that
specific iteration was very much meant
to mirror off of Matt Smith's doctor
specifically so if if they try and
reinvigorate the dreamlord I would think
logically it would be a different
iteration to go with a different
regeneration but like I
find a reason
he's so good
number four
the Beast another two-parter this one
from series two The Impossible Planet
and the Satan pit and a villain who I
actually am not sure if he ever should
come back
but wow is he incredible when he was
there while there is an incredible vocal
performance at the center of this
provided by Gabriel wolf this one knows
me as I know him you don't get that much
direct presence of it I mean we see the
Beast later on it kind of possesses Toby
we hear this voice but it's something
about all those things brought together
in the atmosphere of that story
makes him truly seem
impossible
unbeatable
deeply
deeply dangerous
and
on paper
the idea of Doctor Who versus the devil
that sounds kind of dumb actually
but the execution of this is so good and
the Beast goes from moments of being
controlled to clearly just flatly toying
with people
I'm so close don't turn around
and then he tells them their own secrets
back to them
the little boy who lied
the Virgin he knows what's going on he
knows how to mess with you he's having
fun
oh I love it
number three
the empty child
from series one two-parter The Empty
child and the doctor dances this thing
freaks me out
in the best way
firstly like there's just something
unsettling about the look The Design
it's determination but honestly it's one
of the few things where the more we find
out about it the scarier it gets at
least to me
because when we find out that it doesn't
just look like a child it is a child
it is a child that is scared
and just wants his mother
and to know what it's capable of
if you've ever been a parent and know
how
chaotic
and Reckless small children are before
they have a full understanding of the
consequences of their actions or or a
fully developed moral compass
that much power in the hands of a child
that can't and will never understand the
actual consequences of what it is doing
terrifies me
and it's just so masterfully executed
that thing creeps me out and I freaking
love it
number two
the family of blood
from the two-parters human nature and
the family of blood everything about
this the performances from all four I
mean the main highlight being son of
mine all your little Tin Soldiers
tell me sir
will they thank you
um but all of them are great just
bringing that otherworldliness that
slight hmm you know that those slightly
off just okay
it's not just that you aren't talking
quite like a normal person like a human
there's something about your presence
and the way you're even just looking at
people
something else is going on and it feels
dangerous
and the determination the way they work
together just the off-kilter way in
which they talk to each other referring
to each other strictly by what that
individual's relationship to the one
Speaking is so yes there's
um there's sister of mine and mother of
mine if son of mine is talking but then
if mother is talking it's daughter of
mine and Son of Man son of mine and it
the the terminology is just one more
weird Quirk that makes it a little bit
more strange a little bit more alien and
they are so focused so determined so
single-minded in their pursuit of the
doctor and the way that some of them
turn on a dime into anger going from
calm I'm in control to shouting shut up
stop talking
mother of mine is dying to meet you and
that can honestly go bad it's very
possible for that to go bad because when
you try and have a character who's in
control they start to shout it
undermines that most of the time because
people with a real power don't shout but
because just the way these people talk
is already off it works here in a way
that it usually doesn't when it twists
and goes from calm to shouting to back
oh they're so engaging and they're so
hypnotic to watch
but they're not going to take the top
spot
because for me
when it comes to one-time villains
there's only one that was ever gonna be
at the very very top of this list
number one
the midnight entity
from the episode midnight from series 4.
we don't know what it was
we don't know what it wanted we don't
know if it was trying to deliberately
cause harm
or if it was just an unfortunate side
effect of just its own natural life
cycle we know almost nothing
about the midnight entity
and I don't ever want that changed
it's
perfect in its lack of information
we only know how it operates because of
what we see as it takes over Sky
Silvestri the just this woman out and
about on this vacation
takes her over and then she starts
repeating things that she hears
until it starts sinking up
and saying things at the exact same time
bananas
the Medusa Cascade
[Music]
and then it zeros in on the doctor and
it starts talking ahead of him
do we have a
steals his voice puts the doctor that
doctor a particular tenant's doctor in a
situation where one of his go-to things
one of the things that gets him out of
trouble almost all the time
just talking
his way out of things talking his way
into a plan talking to stall for time
talking
makes it more
powerful
this is quite possibly the ultimate
Foe for tenant that he could not beat
he couldn't
he was saved when the stewardess
sacrificed herself to kill this thing
the doctor couldn't beat it
didn't know what it was
didn't know how it did what it did
know what it was trying to accomplish
and all of that just makes it all the
better
huh
I love
everything
about this episode and this entity
whatever it is I don't ever want to know
because that uncertainty just makes it
work better
what do you think
we're the best one time appearing Doctor
Who villains if you want to give your
shout outs for some options for Classics
as well feel free to do that even though
I didn't cover them in this list
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it patreon is what pays the
bills and enables me to do this as my
living
any amount that you can donate to that
is incredibly helpful I'm gonna have
taxes coming up soon but even if you
can't
like share subscribe also help me out
there's links to other things that I
have done or am doing down in the
description if you want to check out any
of those
don't worry too much about it though
because what I really want you to
remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
hero or villain
you are the council
I'm just running the meetings
and until next time
this Council
is adjourned
[Music]
and now my thanks to my highest
supporters on patreon Robin Moore zuman
lafulla Tarak the thing that goes doing
in the anime Oliver B Melinda Walters
emu dalke Leo the Boyd Becky Sparks for
nabilax the poodle
Tracy Scrabble angry Casper Tim price
Adam RDL Taylor Shayla gourlay and
Rosalind Bennett
thanks for your support and if you want
to get your name in the credits check
out the rewards on the patreon
[Music]
foreign